the new to netflix documentary fantastic
fungi features amazing time-lapse
footage filmed by a team of
cinematographers that included this
pioneering filmmaker my name is louis
schwartzberg i'm a filmmaker and i love
to take audiences on journeys through
time and scale and that that's a real
rush let's go behind the scenes and find
out how these time lapses were made for
fantastic fungi
well i think the biggest surprise for
people watching the film
is they think that it's all filmed
outdoors and there's a lot of reasons
why you can't film time lapse of plants
and fungi outdoors number one there's
wind which would make the object shake
and rattle and look like a charlie
chaplin movie number two
there are bugs and other elements that
would interfere with the filming the
light has to be constant you know even
during the day the light fluctuates
so i built a studio on top of my garage
if i was shooting
one frame every 15 minutes that means
i'm shooting
four frames an hour times 24
is 96 frames 96 frames is four seconds
of film
so the way it works is i had somebody
build an intervalometer for me
intervalometer means it triggers a
camera one frame at a time there you go
in 24 hours we'll have one second of
film it also triggers the grow lights to
come on and off and the photo lights and
the photo lights is the beauty light the
gorgeous tabletop
cinematography lighting the grow lights
are these sort of led lights that are
kind of weird and pink i think they were
developed for people growing cannabis
and i'm able to program the grow lights
to be like sunrise and sunset if i leave
the grow lights on 24 hours they die i
set up shots in the morning i check them
at night i realize i've turned it into a
spiritual practice it actually literally
gets me up in the morning because as
soon as i'm out of bed i'm thinking oh i
wonder what the flower did last night is
it still in frame is it in focus i have
to imagine what the framing and the
composition is going to look like
tomorrow or two days from now or a week
from now and that
is a transformational experience because
you have to put your mind into the
mindset and the intention of the flower
or the fungi thinking where it's going
to grow how big will it get and if
you're right boy it's a rush and if
you're wrong it means you just got to do
it all over again
louie and his team consulted mycologists
fungi experts on how to grow mushrooms
in an environment free from bacteria and
bugs for the film
but which was the most photogenic fungus
lion's mane had these little kind of
tiny tentacles that would emerge
and they would wiggle in this really
beautiful wave-like pattern i'd say
roughly you know the ratio of success to
failure it's roughly about one out of
six maybe one out of ten
it's extremely difficult to do when i'm
shooting the close-up of the fungi
growing we create a miniature set moss
and logs and rocks time lapse macro
cinematography your depth of field is
very shallow we use a macro lenses a 100
millimeter canon 180 millimeter canon
and a 35 millimeter micro lens so
naturally the audience will won't be
focusing on the background if i'm doing
more of a master shot
where we use for example motion control
we will put up a blue screen
and then we will composite in a sky or a
forest to really make it believable to
be able to move the camera
was something that was impossible to do
in special effects
prior to motion control cinematography
so with motion control they took cameras
and combined it with computers to do a
repeat move meaning it shoots one frame
it stops shoots another frame and stops
and you have this controlled dolly move
while the mushroom is growing basically
it's dolly track and a tripod head that
now has little motors on it that enables
the computer
to program a pan a tilt and the length
of the move on the dolly as well as
control the camera and focus all these
things have to be working together
as if it was a real time shot
but one critical component of the fungi
story was impossible to film using
traditional techniques
the mycelium is like the tree
and the mushroom is like the apple to
the tree the mycelium
an underground root-like system that
branches out kind of like the internet
connecting plants and trees to each
other you got a couple of problems here
a no light
b
smaller than the eye can see it's only
one cell thick so what we did
was we used scanning electron
microscopic photography for the electron
microscope to work they work in a lab on
a giant slab of concrete because any
vibration would ruin the shot you take
the specimen and you put it under the
microscope and you bombard it with
electrons and you get the most
extraordinary close-up detail that is
unimaginable to the human eye and we use
those images as a reference for
computer generated animators to use and
we created these incredible shots of
traveling through the mycelial network
throughout his career louis has pushed
the envelope of our visual language both
in terms of tech and artistry he also
pioneered the stock footage industry the
company he formed to license his vast
library of clips was eventually bought
by getty images
i started shooting time lapse four
decades ago by looking at time-lapse
clouds back in 1970 when i pioneered the
first 35-millimeter cameras that could
go outdoors and shoot one frame at a
time
shooting fungi and flowers and plants i
basically have a camera rolling 24 hours
a day
seven days a week
from commercials to imacs to feature
films it's impossible to not have seen
the work of louis schwartzberg at some
point in your life
i love to film hummingbirds again
looking at life from their point of view
enables you
to realize that all of life
has a different metabolic rate and i
think all of life has a different frame
rate
so for example a mosquito on your arm
you know having a little drop of blood
takes a look at that hand coming towards
it in ultra slow motion and has plenty
of time to take off because its
metabolic rate its
lifespan is way shorter than our
lifespan and our lifespan is way shorter
than the redwood tree's lifespan this
reality of you know real real-time human
point of view is not the only point of
view and that's really the beauty of
cameras and time-lapse cinematography
it's actually a time machine and you
could talk about this stuff in
scientific terms you get to have
einstein explain the theory of
relativity but until you see it you
really don't get it
the longest thing i've ever shot
was a mouse rotting you can say that
decomposition is the end of life i argue
that it's the beginning of life you see
this kind of rippling of the fur and
then that kind of dissipates and then
you see some bones and then you see the
grass grow up in between to observe
the pattern and the rhythm of how it
decomposes is actually really beautiful
louie's art has given him a unique
perspective on nature time and the
nature of time
what i'm really engaged with is really
trying to understand you know the
intelligence of nature and how we can
live in harmony with it
and that means at times using you know
time lapse camera to be able to observe
it in their time frame it's a shared
economy under the ground where nutrients
and food are shared for ecosystems to
flourish
without greed and i personally believe
that should be the model for how we
should live our lives we should take
that wisdom from below the ground and
bring it above the ground